hi I'm David and this is my attempt to
send the radio-controlled airplane into
the edge of space using a weather
balloon the internet is full of videos
of people sending things high into the
atmosphere but David notched up 700,000
hits and made it into our top 5 because
he decided to pilot his plane back down
this is quite amazing
he sent his glider all the way up in
space and he could still control it that
the marvelous piece of engineering the
plane is now 20 miles away so how is
David gonna pull this off David is
actually controlling his glider using
radio waves but if he has a standard
radio wave antenna he would need a lot
of power to be able to control that
glider so he has to face signal boosters
onto all his radio equipment but what he
does to increase the range is make them
directional so rather than the radio
waves scattering all over the place
they're focused into a tight beam which
means they're able to go much further
but if you go off axis with it you will
lose the connection and of course lose
control so he's got his mate in the car
so when he releases a glider they
desperately drive along trying to track
the glider underneath so they can stay
in contact with it so by making his
antenna directional David can control
this glider over 20 miles away I'm
starting to pilot the plane and I glide
for as long as I can just to enjoy the
scenery
despite a rough landing
David's flight is a hit with our experts
he was able to control this glider and
fly it down so I think that this was a
highly successful mission for it